-Kevin, good to see you again.
Danielle,
first time on our show.
-I know.
-You know, your --
your daughters weirdly
made a cameo on my show.
-Yes, they did.
-When we were
interviewing Kevin.
During Zoom, they both just
hopped onto the camera,
if you can see them up there.
-Oh, yeah.
There they are.
-Look at how cute.
So now I have the whole --
I've had --
I have your whole family.
-The whole crew
has been on the show now.
-On the show, yeah.
-They went on first.
-Yeah, I know.
-Yeah.
Sorry about that.
-Was it fun
having them around
for interviews?
-Oh, you know,
they made it a game.
They were like,
"I'm gonna make sure
that every interview is more
difficult than it needs to be."
-Yeah.
-But it was fun.
It was a way for us
to bond as a family.
-Yeah. I heard that Questlove
D.J.'d your wedding.
Is that true?
-Yep.
-He did. Actually, I just
saw him at the Oscars.
And he -- and he said --
-You were great,
by the way, bud.
-Oh, thank you.
I had so much fun.
It was weird to be asked
to play for Reba McEntire,
and you're just like...
-What an honor.
-"Okay, yes."
You know?
-Yeah.
-And so, I actually called her.
I'm like, "So this weird thing
has happened."
It was wonderful, but then I saw
Questlove and his mother,
which was awesome.
-I know, his mom...
-So nice.
And she was -- he told her
that, "This was my first
celebrity wedding I D.J.'d."
-Is that right?
-That's what he said.
Or D.J. gig.
I'm not sure if it was,
you know, wedding or D.J. gig.
-Yeah.
And how'd he do?
-He did great.
-He crushed, right?
-I mean, there was a luge
in front of him,
and everybody was like --
-Yeah, everyone
had a great time.
No one ate the food.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-No, of course not.
-So I billed it back to him.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, any uneaten food --
Yeah, Questlove has to pay
for it if the D.J. is too good.
-Too good.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got to be a little bad
so you can finish the food.
Yeah, exactly.
Did he take any requests
from you?
-No requests.
-Yeah, me too. Yeah.
He sees me come up to the thing,
he's like, "Just go away.
Just go."
-"Get out of here."
-He's like,
"Please leave me alone." Yeah.
-But then, you know what?
There was no requests needed.
He was so unbelievable.
-Yeah, he's a great D.J.
I want to talk about this.
"There's a Rock Concert
in My Bedroom."
You guys wrote this great book.
I have two little girls,
and I know you do, as well.
Do they -- Do they perform?
Is this based on real lives?
Do they want to sing?
Do they -- Do they get nervous?
-I think --
Well, Alena had this recital,
and she was practicing, like,
in the foyer for hours.
And she was like -- I saw her
getting really frustrated.
-Yeah.
-So we'd turn on some music
for her, and we're like,
"Let's just have fun with it."
Like, "You -- You know this."
You know?
-Yeah.
-"You're just getting nervous."
And she ended up
having a lot of fun.
And then when she went on stage,
she remembered everything.
So it was -- it was good.
What's good about the book is
that you can --
I feel like the girls
are so different
that when, like, one comes home,
I ask her, like, "How's school?"
she's like, "It's great."
-Yeah.
-The other one
doesn't say anything.
-Yeah, she's like,
"I don't like school."
-She's like, "I -- I don't
really like talking about this.
I just like boys," you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-I'm dying inside.
-Yeah.
-But I feel like, then,
when I read a book to them and
I'm able to ask them questions,
they open up more.
-How old are they now?
-5 and 8.
-5 and 8. Yeah.
It's the greatest.
That's --
My girls are like that, too.
And it's like, they're reading.
And it's like --
to read a book to them,
this is the perfect,
'cause my youngest one,
she sings songs in her --
in her bedroom and --
with her dolls and stuff.
And she's -- then I go like,
"Oh, sing me that song
you were just singing."
She goes, "I can't.
I have stage fright."
[ Laughter ]
And I go,
"How do you know that word?"
-Yeah. Like,
"Where did that come from?"
-"What stage -- What stage
are you talking about?"
I go -- I'm not --
-"It's just my stage, Dad.
You just don't see it."
-Yeah, exactly.
She's like --
And I'm like, I don't want
to pressure anything, you know,
because I would --
but I remember when I was a kid
and, you know,
performing at my parents'
parties or something like that,
it's like, you get nervous.
But then,
once you get through it --
I mean, I'm used to it now.
And now --
Like, do you get nervous when --
-Oh, my God.
-Are you --
[ Laughter ]
Are you nervous now?
-There may have been some
tequila before we came out here.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, no, I mean --
but I mean -- to put you on --
'Cause you're like,
"My husband does that."
-Yeah.
-"I don't perform."
-No.
-Yeah, no, 'cause my wife's
like, "Please. I can't even be
in front of the camera at all."
-She's so incredible, doing it.
-Yeah.
-It's just like --
it makes me so happy
to be able to do stuff with her.
And, you know,
I have to deal
with these other two idiots.
-But that's why we were -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How are --
How are your brothers?
-They're good.
They're really, really busy.
And Joe was just here.
He did so good.
Well, actually, it was awesome.
-He crushed it, man.
He's so fun.
-He can sing his butt off.
-I know.
You guys are great.
But I think this is a --
is a fun book, and I think it'll
build confidence
in any little kid out there.
"There is a Rock Concert
in My Bedroom."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for coming on.
-Thank you.
-You nailed it.
Now I had the whole family on.
Come back, okay?
-Yeah!
-Kevin and Danielle Jonas.
"There's a Rock Concert
in My Bedroom" is out now.